today companies need to share more data
with more teams in more locations than
ever before a number of file sharing and
synchronization services have sprung up
but when shared data increases in size
those services slow down and become
unreliable to the point of being
unusable in addition their weak security
and for manageability capabilities
simply don't meet eyeties needs now
there's a solution a spirit drive
provides a fast reliable secure and
manageable way to share and exchange
large files and data sets between
interconnected teams customers and
partners even virtually unlimited size
files and folders regardless where that
data is located or where it needs to go
it gives your teams the freedom to
access really large files and folders
from their desktop browser mobile device
or email at speeds they can't approach
today with the spirit drive you get an
integrated desktop experience that
enables your teams to remotely browse
shared files and folders directly from
the desktop easily drag and drop files
and folders to initiate high speed
transfers and receive e-mails when
project members access or upload new
content send files and folders to users
and groups via a simple email style
interface keep teams working in unison
thanks to high speed background
synchronization that mirrors local
folders with other drive users or with
content from remote project sites
powering aspera drive is a Sparrow's
high speed transfer platform you can
deploy the transfer platform and your
valuable data wherever you like on
dedicated or hybrid infrastructures
on-premises or in the cloud and just as
important a spare a drive is built on a
powerful security model that combines
authorization and access control with
encryption over the wire and at rest
aspera drive your most effective
solution for sharing data of virtually
unlimited size with teams customers and
partners around the globe want to learn
more contact us to set up a
demonstration or visit us on the